ابناؤه ميسي يتفاعلون مع المونديال ورئيسه
كرواتيا تخطف الاضواء مجددا وسرقه منزل
مدرب المنتخب المغربي هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعونها على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
صرح نجم الكره الارجنتينيه ليونيل ميسي
بانه بعد مباراه السعوديه والتي خسرها
التانجو بهدفين مقابل هدف غادر منه ماتيو
الملعب وهو يبكي فيما اخذتياغو باجراء
الحسابات لمعرفه كيف يتاهل منتخب ابيه في
اخر مونديال للاسطوره الارجنتيه
وجع الملاكم المكسيكي كان له الفريز
تحذيرا الى ليونيل ميسي حيث اتهمه بانه لا
يحترم العلم المكسيكي وذلك عقب المباراه
التي جمعت الارجنتين والمكسيك في
المونديال واثار ميسي غضب الملاكم بعد ما
اظهرت لقطات لقائد منتخب الارجنتين وامامه
قميص المنتخب المكسيكي على الارض في غرفتي
خلع الملابس خلال الاحتفال بعد المباراه
عندما خلع ميسي حذاءه
ظهر وانه امسك القميص بقدمه وهذا الشيء لم
يعجب كمال الله
هل تذكرون كولندا جيتار وفيتش رئيسه
كرواتيا السابقه التي خطفت الانظار في
مونديال روسيا ظهرت اليوم في احد شوارع
قطر وقتها فتى الناس للسلام عليها والتقاط
صور معها كما ظهرت في المدرجات
تعرض منزل مدرب المنتخب المغربي السابق
البسني وحيد خليل لوزيتش للسرقه في فرنسا
بحسب ما اكد مصدر في الشرطه الفرنسيه
ان اللصوص اقتحموا نافذه في الجزء الخلفي
من المنزل ثم استولوا على الخزنه التي
كانت تحتوي على نقود ومجوهرات وساعات
فاخره بقيمه 80,000
€
[موسيقى]